Reeta Panahi is a journalist who was
born in america spent her first years in
iran and has lived in australia ever
since Rita welcome to the Rubin report
thank you for having me greetings from
Melbourne greetings from Melbourne
greetings from Los Angeles I'm going to
I want to dive into some Australia stuff
because we never hear anything about
Australia in America I mean nothing
since Crocodile Dundee - we haven't
heard anything from you guys but let's
start a little bit with your history
because you have a really interesting
history you were actually born in the
United States but you never lived in the
United States correct no not really I
spent my first couple of years there my
parents were there my dad was studying
he was getting his degree in Arkansas so
I was born in down in Pine Bluff
Arkansas and then we moved back to the
Iran which was always the plan and then
the Islamic Revolution happened so
things went pear-shaped in Iran quite
quickly and we're sort of a trapped now
in a country that was entirely different
to before the Revolution and ended up in
Australia and I'm really grateful to be
here really so it's a wonderful place
and I you guys think America's the
center of the world but I really think
Australia is the lucky country as we
call it and you know anybody could do
well in this country yeah and I've heard
you say that in speeches before that you
really think Australia is the the true
place of Tolerance and where everyone
can come and make a better life and all
that sort of stuff so your parents so
they moved to to the state say your dad
was teaching or something right um well
when he was in the States he was getting
his degree so he was at university and
as soon as he graduated they moved back
that was always the plan and and then
when Iran went to hell after the Islamic
Revolution they started looking at how
they could get out because they were
fairly persecuted there and they they it
just wasn't safe and we had family
members locked up had family members
killed it was really hell on earth for
our families
we were looking to leave and the plan
was always to come back to the states
but my dad had a brother in Australia
and we ended up here it wasn't the plan
but it was a lucky lucky chance yeah
people don't realize that before the
Islamic Revolution I mean Arad was a was
a widely secular state in a lot of ways
much more secular than it is now I know
you were really young when you were
there but what are your memories from
being five or six years old
look all the fill and limited memories
baby yeah it was one of the more western
parts of the Middle East you know you
look at pictures of Tara and back in
before the Revolution and you know you
said women in miniskirts and you know
men and women mixing freely and women at
beaches you know we used to live by the
beach before we're in Tehran and then
things changed dramatically you know it
really brings home just how quickly
things can degenerate into what we see
now I mean Iran's progressed a little
bit from when the revolution first
happened as far as its treatment of
women but it's still pretty bloody poor
yeah I remember having to go to school
and then suddenly going from being
fairly carefree and not having to cover
my hair to being in an age we were at
five six years old where you know that
was a time when I had to wear the hijab
that was a requirement and it was just
completely dehumanizing and I just liked
that I liked that change you can just in
my little life from when I was running
around with the boys and being a regular
kid to being expected to observe these
moral codes like making sure my hair's
covered and behaving in a certain way so
even at a tender age I felt the force of
it always knew I was an American citizen
so for me are always identified as
someone other than someone had to live
the rest of their life under that
oppressive system so it was it was
significant for me and I was like me and
one of the original anchor babies I was
like
okay I can't get out one day when I'm 18
I'm not gonna have to be here so that
really was a source of comfort to me
even as a very young child that one day
I'd get out of this what a fascinating
time to grow up because it's not like
people having their formative years when
there isn't change where you just were
going through what you had to go through
but to go from even though you were very
young to having memories of freedom and
that and then as a five-year-old or
whatever that you you knew something was
wrong with being forced into that kind
of system that's it and you know and
even now that kids them particularly
young girls you know for the first few
years they don't have to cover up and
they can run around and then they don't
have these obligations on them but when
they start school then hijabs have to be
warned and you know they're you know not
the best things when you've got a
stinking hot day never mind the rest of
the yeah
and yeah breaks my heart when I see that
when you see the kids the girls
particular having to you know transition
from just being a kid and to being you
know part of the regime yeah what was it
like to actually get out I mean you said
your dad had a brother in Australia well
I assume the regime probably didn't want
their their bright young people to leave
no I know we were really lucky to be
accepted in Australia my mum was a mid
wash it was a actually she was the head
Midwife at a hospital there that was
attended by the royal family before the
Islamic Revolution there was a lot of
pictures of her showing the royal family
around the facilities you know that was
a fairly regular thing with that come
and visit and she'd be the one
responsible it was a bit of a glamour
glamour puss and you know look the part
so they really feared for their life
because there were publications and
pictures of her with the royal family
and you think that might be a minor
thing people got killed for that you
know people we know got imprisoned so we
were lucky to like I said the intention
wasn't to
day in Australia but I ended up staying
here and were granted asylum and it was
just you know yeah forever in debt
indebted to the country because of that
because he gave us a chance in your life
yeah what kind of culture shock was that
like a six year old going from Iran in
the Middle East to an island with you
know people in bordey shorts and all
that oh absolutely and the language was
a shock too because even though I was
born in the States
I had zero English because I you know
been brought up in Iran so I had like
two words hello and T which is a weird
combination of words to know so I had to
learn the language very quickly but it's
such a you know welcoming place and
thankfully English is a very simple
language for a child to learn so you
only took a few months and and yeah it
is a bit of a culture shock but
Australia's not that different that that
you guys imagine honey guys think they
mean everybody anger is you know just a
hobby where I'm that I assume you have a
boomerang within reaching distance of
you right now always I never leave one
room right you never know when you need
it yes yeah it was a culture shock
definitely but you know you immediately
felt safe and very quickly you realize
you know this is a really welcoming you
know wonderful place to to grow up and
so much opportunity yeah did you
experience any discrimination or
anything like that or really was it just
simply you were there over the years I'm
not beating it out for like over 30
years so you know I have seen occasional
discrimination but really it is minor
and it's been quite often there the
discrimination I say are from your you
know your bloody social justice warriors
it's supposed to be the most tolerant
you know open-minded people in the world
but if you don't conform to their idea
of what a brown person should be saying
and doing and thinking then that quite
often really vicious and beneath that
thin veneer of goodness is is a
bigot and I've seen that quite a lot on
Twitter and it's probably the most
racism up and her face has been on
Twitter from from the lunatic left right
because your because somehow you're a
brown do you do identify his Muslim you
consider yourself X Muslim or do you
consider yourself Muslim or I'm not even
call myself eggs X Muslim my family I'm
Muslim like if you ask them what's your
religion that's a Muslim but they're
very very relaxed about it they're
Muslim in the way most Australians are
Christian it's one big difference
between Australia and America where a
lot less religious than you guys and and
so but I surely as I could remember
identified as atheist I just didn't
believe and so for me there wasn't a
real big transition from being a Muslim
to being an agnostic or an atheist
because I never was practicing you know
I don't think my parents have ever been
to a mosque certainly not me so they're
not at all devout so that's interesting
that the the discrimination which you
face which you're describing is very
little and mostly on Twitter which is
not reality I keep trying to remind
myself that Twitter is not reality
but you're getting it you're getting the
discrimination from the social justice
crew because you're not you're not their
type of brown person because you do
speak your mind absolutely it is
extraordinary of these people who
supposedly spend their lives fighting
for the for the minorities that you know
they say is perpetually oppressed even
in countries like Australia when a minor
who actually speaks up and has their own
thoughts that they and it doesn't
conform to their worldview they are
absolutely appalling in in their
response straight-out
bigotry and you know it's like if you're
in a certain race or if you have a from
a minority group you should only vote a
certain way you know you're not allowed
the opportunity to think of yourself and
decide for yourself who who you're gonna
support or where you're going to stand
on certain issues and yeah like I said
beneath that thin veneer of virtue quite
often
there
really hateful bigoted when someone is
you know identifies as a social justice
warrior and I've got no qualms about
mocking them day and night I just think
that quite often horrid people who
deserve to be called out yeah and and
you get a lot of crap for calling them
out but it doesn't stop you but I agree
of course I mean it's such a dim view of
the world that they have that we should
all be viewed in this collectivist space
but before we go all in on that stuff
tell me a little bit about Australia
because boomerangs and kangaroos and
reverse Coriolis effect in your toilet
aside I feel like nobody in the States
knows anything about Australia you're a
big island that's pretty much it well
we're a big island most of the
population lives along the coast love
desert in the middle it's a really
modern I think it's a lot like the
States except we're not really just
that's one of the things we look at you
and we don't sort of identify we've had
a prime minister who was an atheist and
we had no issue with that at all I mean
she was a terrible prime minister but
not because she was an atheist nothing
they would be regardless
no they had nothing to do with it
we've had a lot of prime ministers
recently we've had a modern history of
being really stable particularly
politically but in the last six seven
years we seem to just keep knifing our
prime ministers look they get elected
and then their own party knights them
and then we have another one so that's
kind of characterised the politics in
recent years I'm quite a conservative
government at the moment but led by a
man who many conservatives don't really
see as a conservative so it's a really
interesting period and you just hung on
because a lot of the conservative base
abandoned their party and went and voted
for minor parties so it's really
interesting seeing what's happening
around the world and with you guys
because there does seem to be this
uprising from from conservatives where
they don't actually think the the major
party is or the the major establishment
I guess isn't really representing their
interests and in Australia we had you
know a lot of minor parties and some of
them described as far-right get a lot of
votes in the last
mm yeah so I think Americans think that
everybody is like us like oh we're a
two-party system even though I keep
saying on this show the Constitution
never says anything about only having
two parties it's just that the two
parties have a strangle in our system
you guys have a bunch of parties that
sort of trade power and and it's not
just two parties on top of everything
right that's right well we've got a
labor which is a predominant Left Party
and then we've got the Conservatives
which are liberal and national and they
are in coalition together and then we've
got a minor party called the greens
which maggot-like one in ten votes so in
the Senate our house they have to have a
presence but this last election the
minor parties from all weird facets you
know the House Senate is an absolute
dog's breakfast you know is I'm gonna be
fascinating to see how we can govern for
the next few years because you've got so
many Mike so many minor parties that I
have got their own little objection
objectives and you wonder how they're
gonna work together and and agree and
pass legislation so so yeah we do we
have a very different system to you it's
a party based system we don't vote for
her for a leader
Prime Minister we vote for our
representative in our local seats so
it's a little bit different but though
we don't directly vote for the Prime
Minister it whoever is leading the party
is significant obviously and has a fair
fair deal to do with who gets elected
yeah so it's kind of there's benefits
and drawbacks to both right because here
yeah that there is there is um and you
know you've got particularly the Senate
when you've got so many different
parties you know you can have the vote
diluted and our Senate is a really weird
system every single state is entitled to
the same number of senators so you might
have a very populous state like New
South Wales or Victoria but we get the
same number of Senators as Tasmania
which is you know know what it was there
so it's not a one vote one value so it's
it's it's mad I mean I I'd be very much
for abolishing
and Senator upper house because it's
very much obstructionist and
unrepresentative but that ain't gonna
happen anytime soon it's an argument
that's been made decades and and you
know still there